el gobierno alemán explicó que tiene
pruebas inequívocas basadas en los
hallazgos de un laboratorio
especializado en las fuerzas militares
de que el opositor ruso alexéi navalni
fue envenenado con un agente químico
nervioso de la familia del no que
la respuesta política de parte del
gobierno alemán ante este hallazgo fue
inusualmente enfática el ministro de
exteriores- hi comas explicó que convocó
al embajador ruso en berlín mientras la
canciller alemana angela merkel explicó
en una declaración de prensa que naval
ni fue víctima de un crimen que ella
condena este hecho de manera vehemente y
que el caso genera preguntas que sólo el
gobierno ruso puede y debe contestar el
gobierno alemán ya explicó los
siguientes pasos discutir con los socios
europeos y con la otan cuál podría ser
una reacción común aún se desconocen los
detalles de esa posible reacción pero
sin duda crece la presión para que el
gobierno alemán vaya más allá de las
simples palabras mientras tanto el
hospital berlinés donde se encuentra
navalny emitió un comunicado en el que
explica
y continúa en condición seria que sigue
en cuidados intensivos pero que sus
síntomas están mejorando